one of the things that was so satisfying
about civil war was of course the Black
Panther people came out of that movie
going I want to know more about that
character we want the wow factor but
it's not just stuff blowing up it
definitely is a character piece what
happens now determines what happens to
the rest of the what Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby created Black Panther in the early
60s and he's been a staple of Marvel
Comics 50-plus years he's an interesting
character that is gonna be such a
different thing for the audience on the
screen I couldn't see the Black Panther
living on the side street New York I
love the idea of a superhero who lives
in Africa he has to look out for an
entire nation that's a responsibility
that the other superheroes don't
commonly have and even though he's the
head of a tribe he's a hell of a lot
more than that as his powers begin to
unfold that
a lot of fun don't please never face I'm
super sight about when African King was
also strong enough fast enough smart
enough to do something things that's how
about doing it scribble
there's something very special about him
who can see a superhero in a different
light different world
so this is not a goodbye
only is see you later as a wrap for me
on affinity wars couldn't be more
excited to see how they put this
together I'm very excited I'm also sad
to go home and see my baby hey everybody
we got a whole bunch of new Black
Panther and Avengers for to talk about
and I'm wondering if it has something to
do with the actual title for Avengers
for which Kevin Feige has said has been
blown out of proportion like he said
that it's not going to blow everyone's
minds
it's just that for non comic-book
readers it could potentially be a
spoiler in it's kind of confusing but if
you're a big comic book reader then you
already probably have a pretty solid
idea of what the story's going to be and
how it's gonna play out with the
resolution of the Infinity Gauntlet saga
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's also new black panther they
confirm that they're gonna be dropping
next week too
this is mostly meant to be behind the
scenes stuff but I like the way that
Kevin Feige has been appearing and all
these featurettes that they've been
posting lately like Black Panther is
freaking amazing so of course everybody
wants to know more about him Stan Lee's
like oh hell yeah he was awesome when I
introduced him back there in the 60s so
you see a couple of different comic book
covers like you see Stan Lee Jack Kirby
Black Panther then you see hardcore
blades Marvel Knights Black Panther
which might be a tip-off for what's
going on with the golden Jaguar costume
and some of its hidden functions because
it looks very similar to the Marvel
Knights black panther costume then the
more modern retelling so there's a
couple of different versions of his
origin story that they've told there's
the early mid 2000s version which is
what this panel is from then there's
obviously the more recent stuff the more
recent stuff is really where you should
start if you're brand new to the
character showing you how much cooler
the technology is the culture then
anything that you would find in like New
York City Stark has some really cool
stuff but not every single piece of his
technology makes it to all the different
labs in the way that all of the
technology of Wakanda is hardcore
advanced the really big scenes that you
see pieces of during this are from the
big action scenes so obviously there's
warrior falls which goes all the way
back to Stanley Jack Kirby era there'll
be a lot of Stanley in this but the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is
mostly influenced by what they did
visually with the first iron man movie
is more of a tech based universe like
they did spider-man homecoming instead
of them being mutants or actual animals
they're more tech based so like the
vulture doesn't actually have vulture
wings he this is a mechanical blight
suit so a lot of that trickles into
Black Panther but part of the big deal
with Black Panther from a design
standpoint isn't being completely
different than anything you've seen
before so visually it's still very tech
based this is where you're starting to
see a lot of the fusion of culture
technology in what that looks like when
they've been completely isolated from
any sort of outside influence all the
crazy weaponry in the armor that you see
during the big fight scenes with the
best example of that like very tribal
influence but with the level of
something that you would see in an Iron
Man movie but something that you don't
see in any of the trailers and it's
actually kind of funny is that they have
their own version of the internet what
would be more isolating than being
completely disconnected from the world
wide web and having your own
self-contained version of that that they
access with these special beads they
look like ceremonial beads but they're
actually super advanced but like they
have the giant cloaking field so there's
a lot of passive technology that you
need certain things to access while
you're in Wakanda but they'll probably
have some funny way of showing it to you
during the movie almost everybody gets
upgrades some of the characters are
getting vibranium upgrades maybe not
everybody though but getting into
Avengers territory so that Jeremy Renner
clip he's basically wrapped on Avengers
4 there's still a couple characters that
are probably filming scenes because
there's so many of them
he says gone but it's more like see you
later meaning that he will come back in
another movie it doesn't confirm that he
survives Avengers 4 because he is pretty
high on my death predictions list but it
does mean that he's not gone forever in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so of all
the people that are resigning contracts
that need to right now like Chris
Hemsworth Chris Evans now Jeremy Renner
just add into the list of people that
are definitely coming back if they can
for more Marvel movies now we know a lot
of people are asking about Hawkeye
spin-off movie don't worry about any of
that when I say coming back into another
Marvel movie he'll probably show up in
somebody else's movie first because most
of the main Avengers aren't getting
fourth films in phase four as far as we
know the guardians are getting their
third film if any of them get a film all
by themselves in phase four it'll
probably be Thor because Taika Waititi
said that he definitely wants to come
back to do another Thor film and they
made so much money on Ragnarok but
here's the other thing that he implies
you may have caught it at the end and
anthony mackie kind of did the same
thing too and if only one actor had been
doing this then it might have seemed
like a mistake that they were making but
when multiple actors say the same thing
independent of one another it just makes
you double take so he said infinity wars
as in plural not infinity war because
Avengers 3 is called Avengers infinity
war they said that Avengers 4 is going
to be called something different because
the story is so different but that's
mostly because Avengers 3 is more of a
heist film it's like a 70s heist film
because stano's quest and the Infinity
Gauntlet saga is a 70s story and he has
to steal all the gems to form the
gauntlet so it would make sense that
it's a heist film the fourth film is
more like the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline which is the story of the
Avengers fighting him and getting the
gauntlet off of his hand with the help
of the guardians of the galaxy the
collective cosmic concepts it's almost
like the universe itself versus Thanos
like everything in every one in the
universe versus Thanos trying to get him
to take off the Infinity Gauntlet so it
sounds like when Avengers 4 is done what
they'll build them as like when they try
to package the movie in a 2 DVD set like
by both movies because it's kind of like
a two-part story even though technically
the titles are different they'll just
call it Avengers the infinity Wars and
that'll be like the title of the box set
but obviously you have 10 years of
Marvel movies building towards this so
they're gonna try and sell some crazy
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 collective box
set let me know in the comments though
what do you think about Jeremy Renner
and Anthony Mackie both separately
saying Avengers infinity wars as in
plural what that says about the title of
Avengers 4 the other funny thing you may
have noticed during all that black
panther footage is that one of the comic
book panels of the Avengers fighting
each other has Hawkeye in it and he's a
scroll it's like a reveals as a scroll
Hawkeye fighting the other Avengers so
you're like wait a minute this is studio
produced material meaning that somebody
had to approve
this why is there a scroll in this
footage does that mean that Hawkeye is
going to be the scroll in the Avengers
team because during the Captain Marvel
movie they're gonna reveal the Scrolls
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
makes sense that you Tia something as
big as that that it turns out that one
of the characters that we've been
watching this whole time is secretly a
scroll and it's sort of a version of
Secret Invasion without actually doing
that storyline so just let me know in
the comments if one of the characters on
the Avengers or one of the good
characters has been a scroll this whole
time who do you think that it is do you
think it's Hawkeye or do you think that
it's somebody else there's a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about
Marvel related stuff on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video okay / please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll just name a new winner when I post
new Avengers I know a lot of you been
making some requests about doing a
Hawkeye video because of his different
costume and persona but click here to
learn about all the vibranium upgrades
that people are getting during infinity
war and click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]